now to California we're seemingly an
endless a barrage of storm fronts is
wreaking havoc all across the state
thousands are still under evacuation
orders in Northern California which has
been hammered by days of heavy rain and
powerful winds Carter Evans is in hard
hit Santa Cruz County south of San
Francisco Carter good morning
good morning this is the San Lorenzo
river that you see behind me and it's
just one of many rivers that have
already flooded it with more rain on the
way the flooding may not be over just as
many people are cleaning up from the
last storm
it's a race to clear the roads before
the rain begins again
rescue teams in Sonoma County found one
woman deceased in her submerged vehicle
as flood waters overwhelmed roads in
wine country
he's one of at least 18 people killed by
the series of severe storms we are not
out of the woods yet we had perhaps more
air rescues than we've ever had on any
other single day in the state's history
so far the storms dumped more than two
feet of rain in some areas the Pajaro
River bordering Santa Cruz is already
overflowing so is the Sacramento River
where residents are being forced out by
Rising water as more storms are expected
through the weekend
in the Bay Area Jose Alvarez spent the
day emptying grain buckets after 70 mile
per hour winds tore the roof off his
apartment we hear this loud bang before
we knew there was water just pouring
inside of our beds in a our clothes and
everything the water came up to here
Howard Berman is still cleaning up after
river water flooded his home he took
this photo from the second floor
everything you could see here
was just covered in Rushing Water it's
great living on the river it's not so
great living in the river near San Luis
Obispo the heartbreaking search
continues for five-year-old Kyle Doan on
what would have been his first day of
kindergarten He Slipped from his
mother's arms during a rescue attempt in
a flood his last words to me was Mommy
it's going to be okay just be calm and
everything will be okay
that water is so dangerous and this
river behind me isn't the only one that
people are worried about there's concern
the Salinas River about an hour south of
me could flood and potentially cut off
major roads if that were to happen it
could strand about 50 000 people on the
Monterey Peninsula and Nate that
includes an entire Naval Base
Carter thank you